c'était un moment merveilleux parce que
x ya dix ans je les récuse sur la scène
là dans le jury donc tout ce que vous
vous étiez pas ce que c'est les 10 ans
de votre sac ouais nous les dix ans mon
sac ben vous n'avez pas pris une ride
merci j'ai pu être dans le jury de miss
france donc c'est incroyable de voir ça
de l'autre côté et les filles étaient
très belles elles n'ont pas démérité
elle s'était tout une belle soirée une
présence était très belle c'est ce qui
se passe alors à côté nous que ce qui se
passe quand on arrive déjà un pour miss
france est ce que on les voit d'abord
quand on est jury ou pas du tout on y
voit pas du tout non non non pas vrai
donc là le jure il élabore réunis dans
une dans une petite pièce on nous donne
les consignes on nous explique comment
fonctionnent les boîtiers d'accord parce
qu'on vous a influencé non non non non
non vous aviez un bouquet vous aviez
tous des bienfaits on est un bouc
effectivement là d'une boucle et
services et donc qui a toutes les
candidates qui sont dedans avec des
annotations
sur leur comportement par exemple sur ce
qu'elles ont montré pendant le voyage
d'intégration et autres on arrive à
placer à mais la personnalité au delà
juridique j'ai donc c'est très important
de rappeler que bien sûr c'est un
concours de beauté mais c'est aussi un
concours
de culture générale de comportement de
présence sur scène surgit on peint on
regarde bien sûr l'homme jeté votre
favori c'était votre favorite ou pas
voilà est en fait diane ce que je
voulais dire c'est que va arriver dans
un ce soir là donc samedi soir c'est la
fille qui a réuni tous ces critères là
ah ouais la beauté bien sûr du visage du
corps mais la présence l'énergie le
discours elle ce soir là elle avait tout
elle ne s'est pas laissé submerger par
l'émotion et c'était elle qui n'avait
l'énergie s'était tu t'en berrocal ouais
elle avait pas dit non mais c'est vrai
mais d'énergie vous l'avez sorti vous
avez senti que les ailes et tout le
monde est à parce que dans le jury vous
êtes parler alors c'est quoi ce jury
d'ailleurs qu'elle a été élue
pour le vote du public et est troisième
c'est ça gilbert des
premiers alors miss martinique a été
première tout le temps et miss ile de
france et est troisième du public et le
jury amie miss martinique cinquième
c'est ça qui donne beaucoup d'accords
hier que miss martinique a perdu parce
qu'elle est cinquième du jury a mille
fois et miss ile de france elle est
magnifique elle est magnifique très
bonne mine non mais là je dis que ce qui
a influé dans le classement c'est le
vote du jury et ça a été un peu étonnant
que miss martinique soit cinquième du
jury alors qu'elle avait beaucoup de
qualités et moi
comment justement c'est vrai que pour
gagner il faut séduire un mix le public
est aussi le jury c'est vrai que le jury
était constitué de deux personnes de la
télé de deux personnes voilà
exactement est en fait le vote du public
c'est quoi c'est si vous êtes si vous
promener d'une région qui vote beaucoup
vous aurez aussi beaucoup plus de voix
ça ne veut pas dire que c'est vous qui
devriez vraiment gagner c'est pour ça
que la présence du jury est très
importante et je le rappelle c'est un
concours vraiment qui fédère toute la
france un programme familial qui fait
des audiences alors justement les
audiences 7,3 millions de
téléspectateurs alors et 42 3% de pda
alors je voulais bien 42 3% ça veut dire
que si on 100 % des gens qui regardaient
la télé ce soir là il y avait 42 3% donc
il regardait alors en pda c'est beaucoup
mieux on sent que ça perdu 1,3 million
de téléspectateurs ce qui montre que la
télévision voilà père et moi regarder
les spectateurs je vous dis est ce assez
incroyable des pmp
je crois le peut-être le seul programme
à avoir progressé entre l'année dernière
et cette année en nombre de
téléspectateurs pour vous dire c'est
vrai que c'est incroyable série parce
que voilà même miss france a perdu garde
le nombre voilà alors pourcentage son
préau mais ils ont perdu 1,3 million de
téléspectateurs la série qu'il ya moins
de gens qui regardent la télévision en
tout cas qui ont regardé samedi soir
voilà en tout cas c'est toujours un
magnifique score et c'était un carton
énorme parce que en termes de parts de
marché c'est un des record 42 3%